teilchenbeschleunigung auf wenigen
millimetern eine neue bahnbrechende
technologie ermöglicht die
teilchenbeschleunigung nicht in riesigen
beschleunigern sondern auf dem raum von
wenigen millimetern und mit diesem
teilchenbeschleunigern trend in die
medizin revolutioniert werden jetzt in
science fiction herzlich willkommen
teilchenbeschleuniger ja kennen wir
bisher so riesige bahn mit elektrischen
feldern in die teilchen gedrängt werden
um dann auf fast die
lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt zu
werden dann werden sie zur kollision mit
wiederum anderen teilchen gebracht und
so werden neue teilchen entdeckt ja hier
werden wirklich bahnbrechende
erkenntnisse gewonnen
zb im fern- im large hadron collider lhc
ist 27 kilometer lang und wird von 100
staaten finanziert wie eine welt
forschungsanlage eine außergewöhnliche
zusammenarbeit erst vor wenigen tagen
meldete der lhc eine mögliche anomalien
die so im standardmodell der
teilchenphysik nicht vorhergesagt wird
der lhc ist auf der suche nach der neuen
physik vielleicht fündig geworden
wir halten euch hier für pixum natürlich
auf dem laufenden wenn es konkret wird
wenn man aber beschleunigte teilchen in
der praxis einsetzen will dann sind
solche ringe love und
teilchenbeschleuniger ziemlich
unpraktikabel einfach riesig teuer und
neuer wenig transportabel in einer art
praxis oder klinik hätte ein solcher
teilchen beschleuniger kaum platz die
lösung ist der kiel fällt oder auffällt
beschleuniger ein leser
teilchenbeschleuniger diese neue
technologie ist in der lage teilchen
nicht in kilometer langen tunneln sind
auch nicht hunderte meter es sind nicht
mal meter es sind millimeter zu
beschleunigen
wie bitte wort wir sind heute in der
lage teilchen auf einer kleinstem raum
zu beschleunigen auf millimetern
wofür brauchen wir dann wie wir riesigen
anlagen alles eine fehlinvestition
verschwörungstheoretiker die nicht zum
logischen denkens in der lage sein
würden jetzt davon ausgehen dass das
alles geplant
geldverschwendung
arbeitsplatzbeschaffung und so weiter
ist das ist aber natürlich alles quatsch
noch ist eben dieser laser
teilchenbeschleuniger in der
entwicklungsphase
die technologie ist noch nicht
ausgereift aber sie hat ein riesiges
potenzial teilchenbeschleunigung auf
wenigen millimetern
die technologie ist bestechend einfach
mit milliardstel sekunden bruchteilen
kurzen energiereichen laserpulsen wird
auf eine folie geschossen dabei werden
die negativ geladenen
elektronen herausgegriffen hinziehen die
positiv geladenen protonen wie an einem
gummiband hinter sich her und
beschleunigen sieht und die
beschleunigten teilchen von ihr zum
beispiel für die bekämpfung von krebs
verwendet werden im gegensatz zur
röntgenstrahlung können die
beschleunigten teilchen nämlich so in
den körper geschossen werden dass sie
nur die betroffenen tumore treffen
röntgenstrahlung trifft auf seinem weg
zum tumor auch gesundes gewebe und
verursacht so unter umständen wieder
neuen krebs wie es mit dem neuen
teilchenbeschleuniger weitergeht und
wann es die ersten ergebnisse für die
medizinische anwendung gibt das erfahrt
ihr natürlich hier bei klickst du wenn
er mir hier ein abo aufs auge drückt und
vergesst nicht mir einen genau auf die
glocke beginnt
hier gibt es die besten videos von pixum
einfach draufklicken und genießen hatte
sie verpasst haben sollte
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran